Das hier ist Eiweiß, das so schmeckt wie
Hühnereiweiß und auch noch die genau gleichen
Nährwerte hat. Unter dem Mikroskop kann man es
nicht von echtem Hühner-Eiweiß unterscheiden.
Der einzige Unterschied: Es ist komplett ohne
Tiere entstanden. Ähnlich wie Laborfleisch,
über das wir ja auch schon mal ein
Video gemacht haben. Und das Beste:
Diese neue Technologie funktioniert nicht nur
für Eier, sondern für quasi jedes Protein,
jeder andere Inhaltsstoff, der Tierprodukte
zu dem macht, was sie sind. Milch, Käse,
Fleisch! All das könnte bald “vegan”,
aber trotzdem echt auf den Markt kommen.
In diesem Video sprechen wir
darüber, wie revolutionär das ist,
was das für unsere Zukunft bedeutet
und warum Europa diese Technologie…
anscheinend komplett verschläft. Willkommen
zu einem neuen Video bei Doktor Whatson.
#intro
Woher kommt also das Ei ohne Huhn? Die Methode
dahinter heißt Präzisionsfermentation. Klingt
kompliziert, aber Menschen nutzen Fermentation
schon seit Jahrtausenden. Das heißt einfach,
dass bestimmte Stoffe von Mikroben oder Enzymen in
andere umgewandelt werden. Bier, Käse, Brot – ihr
habt wahrscheinlich heute mindestens ein Mal etwas
Fermentiertes gegessen oder getrunken, Prost. In
China wurden schon vor 9.000 Jahren fermentierte
Getränke aus Reis, Honig und Früchten geschlürft.
Das ist die traditionelle Fermentation,
quasi kontrolliertes Verderben von Lebensmitteln.
So machen Milchsäurebakterien Milch zu Joghurt,
oder Weißkohl zu Sauerkraut. Hefen machen aus
Traubensaft Wein. Anfangs sind diese Produkte
zufällig entstanden. Milch und rohes Gemüse
sind jetzt nicht gerade für lange Haltbarkeit
bekannt, aber durch die Fermentation
entstanden neue haltbare Lebensmittel.
Bei der Präzisionsfermentation – die
ist jetzt neu – wird aber vom Ende aus
gedacht. Forschende fragen sich: Welches
Molekül mit welchen Eigenschaften brauche
ich? Anschließend wählen sie die Mikroorganismen
aus, modifizieren und füttern sie. Zum Beispiel
Hefen oder Bakterien. Und die verarbeiten
dann das Futter zum gewünschten Produkt.
Bei Onego Bio aus Finnland, die Hühner-Eiweiß
herstellen, sieht das zum Beispiel so aus:
Das Protein Ovalbumin ist das häufigste
Protein vom Hühner-Eiklar. Um es herzustellen,
wird ein Pilz genmodifiziert. Aber keine Sorge,
das ist gar nicht schlimm und dazu kommen wir
gleich. In einem Bioreaktor wird der Pilz mit
Glukose, Mineralien und Stickstoff gefüttert und
produziert das Ovalbumin. Nach der Fermentation
wird es vom Pilz getrennt. Anschließend wird es
zu Pulver verarbeitet, weil es sich so leicht und
günstig transportieren lässt und haltbarer ist.
Obwohl der Pilz eigentlich das gleiche
wie das Huhn macht, ist er deutlich
besser im Huhn-Sein. Zumindest, wenn es
nicht darum geht, draußen auf der Wiese zu
chillen oder als Chicken Wing zu überzeugen,
sondern eben Eiweiß zu produzieren. Ein Huhn
braucht zum Beispiel 27,5 Kilo Futter für ein
Kilogramm Ovalbumin. Der Pilz braucht nur rund
viereinhalb Kilogramm für die gleiche Menge. Auch
im Landbedarf ist das Pilz-Eiweiß deutlich besser:
Je nach Szenario wurden 87 bis 89 Prozent
weniger Land für die Herstellung gebraucht,
und auch die Treibhausgasemissionen sind
35 bis 55 Prozent geringer. Diese Zahlen
schauen wir uns aber gleich nochmal genauer
an, weil es hier ein kleines Problemchen gibt.
Okay, wir haben jetzt also echtes
Hühner-Eiweißpulver, das Pilze für uns
hergestellt haben. Schon ziemlich cool. Aber wer
schon mal probiert hat vegan zu essen, der weiß,
dass die wahre Versuchung Käse ist. Und hier gibt
es wahnsinnig gute Neuigkeiten: Den kann man auch
durch Präzisionsfermentation herstellen! Das
deutsche Unternehmen Formo stellt mit Hefen
Milchproteine wie Kasein her und will dieses Jahr
den Käse daraus in Singapur auf den Markt bringen.
Und Impossible Foods, davon habt ihr vielleicht
schon gehört, stellt Fleischalternativen aus
Pflanzen her, die aber genauso schmecken
sollen wie das Original. Den Ersatzprodukten,
die wir heute in Deutschland kaufen können, zum
Beispiel von Beyond Meat, fehlt dafür aber noch
eine entscheidende Zutat. Das Molekül Häm ist
für den fleischigen Geschmack verantwortlich,
und genau das lässt Impossible Foods
von modifizierten Hefen produzieren.
Theoretisch kann man so alle
möglichen Moleküle herstellen,
und genau die gesuchten Eigenschaften
in Endprodukte bringen: Häm sorgt für
Fleischgeschmack, Ovalbumin für lockeren
Eischnee, Milchproteine für Käsefäden.
Den Bauplan für das gewünschte Produkt bekommen
die Mikroorganismen durch Genmodifikation. Das
ist aber nicht das gleiche wie zum Beispiel
bei GMO-Mais. Die Mikroorganismen sind
im Endprodukt nicht enthalten, sondern
werden nur für die Produktion genutzt.
Klingt fast zu gut, um wahr zu sein: Tierprodukte
ohne Tierhaltung, große Potenziale für die Umwelt,
ohne Pestizide und Landbedarf. Aber wie groß
ist das Umweltpotenzial denn tatsächlich?
Da kommen wir zu einem Problem. Wir konnten keine
unabhängige Studie finden, die die Umweltvorteile
von Präzisionsfermentation prüft. Ja, es stimmt,
dass Mikroorganismen, auf ein Endprodukt bezogen,
zum Beispiel Milchprotein, weniger Energie
“verschwenden” als es Tiere tun. Außerdem
ist es natürlich weniger aufwändig, wenn nur die
Bausteine hergestellt werden, die für besondere
Eigenschaften verantwortlich sind und nicht das
komplette Produkt. Aber bisher gibt es – außer von
den Firmen selbst – keine Angaben dazu, wie groß
diese Zahlen tatsächlich sind oder irgendwann mal
sein werden. Bisher haben sich Universitäten
und andere unabhängige Einrichtungen damit
noch nicht ausführlich auseinandergesetzt.
Und das liegt wahrscheinlich einfach daran,
dass wir hier gerade über die Cutting Edge des
Fortschritts im Ernährungsbereich sprechen.
Dieser ganze Markt entsteht gerade erst.
Die Zahlen der Unternehmen sind natürlich
nicht aus der Luft gegriffen. Trotzdem:
Nicht alle Unternehmen haben schon große
Produktionsstätten. So ein Unternehmen fängt
im Labor an, baut dann eine kleine Pilotanlage und
erst dann wird alles auf Anlagen gescaled, die für
die Massenproduktion ausgelegt sind. Das heißt,
dass zumindest einige Unternehmen heute eigentlich
nur schätzen können, wie groß die Effekte für
verschiedene Umweltaspekte aussehen werden.
In der Analyse von Onego Bio gibt es
aber auch große Unterschiede je nachdem,
wo die Pilze das Eiweiß produzieren.
Das liegt zum Beispiel daran,
dass die Bioreaktoren mit Strom
auf Temperatur gehalten werden
müssen. Und verschiedene Länder haben eben
unterschiedlich viel Erneuerbare im Strommix.
Das bedeutet aber auch, dass es noch Luft
nach oben gibt, wenn dort mehr Erneuerbare
eingesetzt werden. Zum Beispiel in der Zukunft,
wenn wir nur noch erneuerbare Energien in unserem
Strommix haben, dann könnte es fast gar
keinen CO2-Fußabdruck mehr haben. Und man
kann auch noch mehr optimieren: Zum Beispiel,
wenn der Pilz, der das Ovalbumin herstellt,
auch noch genutzt wird. Christopher
Langowski von Onego Bio hat uns erklärt,
dass man daraus zum Beispiel eine Lederalternative
herstellen kann. Oder man füttert den Pilz mit
Lignozellulose aus Holz oder Stroh, was die
Umweltauswirkungen weiter minimieren könnte.
Käse, Ei oder Häm aus Präzisionsfermentation
werden also aller Wahrscheinlichkeit nach deutlich
besser für die Umwelt sein als ihre tierischen
Gegenstücke. Wie groß die Effekte genau sind,
ist von vielen Faktoren abhängig. Was
auch gut ist: Es leiden keine Tiere,
und wir brauchen ohne Tierhaltung
weniger Antibiotika und Pestizide.
Wir hätten für dieses Video richtig gerne
Pilz-Eiweiß und Hefen-Käse probiert. Und immerhin
gibt es in den USA, Israel und Singapur schon
Produkte aus Präzisionsfermentation zu kaufen.
Aber leider sieht das in Deutschland
noch anders aus. Woran liegt das?
Tatsächlich: An der Bürokratie, wer
hätte das gedacht. Genauer gesagt,
an der Novel-Food-Verordnung der EU. Klar, neue
Lebensmittel sollten ausgiebig geprüft werden.
Aber das kann auch ziemlich absurd werden: Ein
Unternehmen musste seinen veganen Ei-Ersatz prüfen
lassen, weil exotische Mungbohnen enthalten sind,
die seit Ewigkeiten in Asien gegessen werden.
Diese Prüfung kann durch die ineffiziente
Bürokratie hier gut und gerne mal mehrere Jahre
dauern, kritisieren Start-ups. In Singapur geht
das deutlich schneller, obwohl die Kriterien genau
so streng seien, sagen Institute aus der Branche.
Und Impossible Foods wartet zum Beispiel schon
seit 2019 auf die EU-Zulassung, obwohl es den
Häm-Burger in Neuseeland längst zu kaufen gibt.
[Eigene Meinung]
Aber wenn es mal soweit ist, werden wir in
ein paar Jahren ganz normal Cheeseburger
mit fermentiertem Häm und tierfreiem Käse essen?
Ehrlich gesagt – Ich kann mir schon vorstellen,
dass Präzisionsfermentation da ein großes
Potenzial hat. Die Umweltauswirkungen der
Tierhaltung sind gigantisch. Die Food and
Agriculture Organization der UN schätzt die
Emissionen auf 7,1 Gigatonnen CO2-Äquivalente
jährlich. Das sind 14,5 Prozent der
Gesamtemissionen und einfach mal so viel wie die
gesamten weltweiten Transportemissionen in 2020.
Trotzdem ist eine große Gruppe an Menschen nicht
bereit, auf Tierprodukte zu verzichten. Wenn die
versteht, dass Produkte aus Präzisionsfermentation
genau die Eigenschaften haben, die sie an
Tierprodukten liebt, könnte das eine Menge
auslösen. Zumindest geben in Umfragen zwischen
30 und 70 Prozent der Befragten an, dass sie
Käse aus Präzisionsfermentation kaufen würden.
Probieren würden ihn je nach Umfrage sogar knapp
80 Prozent. Ihr auch? Schreibt mir das mal in
die Kommentare. Ich gehöre auf jeden Fall dazu
und hoffe darauf, dass ich bald in meine erste
tierfreie Käsepizza beißen kann. Darum hoffe
ich, dass das mit der Zulassung schnell klappt.
Ich find’s immer wieder krass zu sehen und
super faszinierend, was es gerade alles für
Innovationen gibt, woran überall geforscht wird
und wie schnell die Menschheit voranschreitet und
neue Dinge erfindet. Und ich glaube, unter euch
sind einige, denen es genauso geht. Wenn ihr Ideen
für Innovationen habt, dann schreibt euch mal
den 19. Oktober in den Kalender. Da organisiert
PROvendis »GO-Bio Initial«: Eine Veranstaltung
für junge Nachwuchswissenschaftler*innen aus
den Hochschulen in NRW. Da könnt ihr euch
nämlich über Fördermöglichkeiten im “Life
Science”-Bereich informieren. Also zum Beispiel in
den Bereichen Gesundheit, Medizintechnik oder der
Wirkstoffsuche. Ihr könnt hier neue Projektideen
entwickeln oder wenn ihr schon eine Idee habt,
diese weiterentwickeln. Ihr lernt, wie man den
perfekten Antrag stellt und mit etwas Glück gibt
es sogar Geld für eure innovative Idee, denn
es sind auch einige namhafte Institutionen vor
Ort. Und ich bin auch da und werde in einer
Keynote über spannende Zukunftstechnologien
berichten. Vielleicht sehen wir uns also da!
Mit »GO-Bio initial« will das Bundesministerium
für Bildung und Forschung Entwicklungen mit
erkennbarem Innovationspotential fördern
und sie auch schon früh auf eine spätere
Kommerzialisierung ausrichten. Bis Anfang
Oktober könnt ihr euch noch anmelden und dann
sehen wir uns in Essen. Einen Link mit weiteren
Infos und wie ihr euch anmelden könnt,
findet ihr unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Wie immer, vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen.
Bis dahin, bleibt neugierig, euer Cedric.
[Outtake] Hefen machen aus
Taubensaft Wein. Mhhh, Taubensaft.